We're gonna to play a little quiz right here.
This is: Bronco Player or Oscar Winner?
You gotta tell me, if this is a Bronco or an Oscar winner.
-Okay.
-Okay?
-Easy.
Alright. Well, so you say. We'll see. Okay.
Adrien Brody
- He's an Oscar winner.
- That's right.
Aaron Brewer.
Player.
Burt Lancaster.
Actor.
- That's right.
Vance Walker.
...Oscar...
Vance Walker is a Broncos player. You gotta go back to the film tape, come on man.
Jon Voight.
Voight?
- Yes.
Oscar.
- That's an Oscar winner.
Angelina Jolie's dad actually.
Wow.
What an actor too, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah yeah...
What's your favourite Jon Voight movie?
Uhh ... I can't say.
Don't worry about it ...
[laughing]
Britton Colquitt.
Oscar.
Britton Colquitt is a Denver Bronco.
- That's right. That's right.
Are you guys buds?
- Best.... aaaah. No.
No you're not.
Jeremy Irons.
I wanna use the lifeline.
Okay. You guys get to talk to my ex-girlfriend. Alright.
Is Jeremy Irons a Broncos player or an Oscar winner?
[Oscar winner]
Oscar winner.
She says Oscar winner? Ask her how she's doing. Like, how her life's going.
How is your life going?
She can't complain.
Fandango is the best company in the world.
Look out for 'em.
I'm going right now to the movies just because of Fandago.
You should probably practice though. Practice for the Super Bowl.
After practice.